transmettre l'histoire et changer dans
des lieux mythiques
c'est l'objectif de l'exposition fait
divertissement à la cour de versailles
parmi les rois et les reines du château
les enfants à bord de l'histoire de
façon ludique on compare à la découverte
de cette exposition à la fois on
explique l'histoire de ces
divertissements est à la fois on est on
les fait participer avec des petits jeux
par exemple d'odeurs pour la chasse les
remettre dans l'ambiance avec des
recherches dans les salles de certains
instruments musique selon des
descriptions ça permet aussi de donner
un aspect ludique à l'exposition et
justement c'est le thème de cette
exposition donc ça marche plutôt bien
mais qui est marié en planète
c'est en abordant les portraits les
objets mais aussi les loisirs à travers
les salles que les enfants comprennent
les habitudes les activités et même la
cruauté de l'époque
alors qui n'est jamais qu'une machine
que l'on appelle la guillotine ce qui
fonctionne bien je dirais que c'est la
partie jardin parce qu'on on voit
vraiment des des jeux notamment les
patins à glace ça marche bien parce
qu'on a un repère aussi par rapport aux
anneaux activités d'aujourd'hui aussi
les jeux de société voilà avec les
exemples de jeux de cavaniol par exemple
les aime toujours bien joué avec les
petites billes avec les petits olive il
se met vraiment contexte un cadre
idyllique pour s'amuser mais aussi pour
apprendre l'histoire des rois de france
dès le plus jeune âge